AS WE JUMP TO
OUR NEXT GAME, KENTUCKY DERPY.
KENTUCKY DERPY.
WELL, FOLKS, THE KENTUCKY DERBY
IS UPON US.
UH, I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
I WAS BORN IN LOUISVILLE,
KENTUCKY.
THAT MAKES ME NOT REALLY THAT
RELATED TO THIS HORSE RACE.
UH, BUT IT IS THAT FESTIVE
OCCASION WHERE THOUSANDS OF
SOUTHERN GENTLE REDNECKS IN HATS
GATHER TO MAKE ASSES OF
THEMSELVES FOR FUN AND SPORT,
ESPECIALLY THIS GUY.
>> ...UM, WEAKENED TO FINISH
BACK AT THE REAR OF THE FIELD...
>> HARDWICK: UH-OH!
WELL, LET'S NOT LET A PASTY
WHITE GUY BUTT DISTRACT US FROM
WHAT THIS EVENT IS ALL ABOUT,
CRAZY HORSE NAMES.
PAST RACES HAVE FEATURED HORSES
WITH NAMES LIKE BODACIOUS TATAS
OR WHATAMICHOPPEDLIVER AND, OF
COURSE, TURDUCKEN.
THOSE WERE ALL REAL HORSE NAMES
THAT HAVE COMPETED.
SO, COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY KENTUCKY
DERBY-WORTHY HORSE NAMES AS YOU
CAN IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, STEVE.
>> FUNNY YOU DON'T LOOK
GLUE-ISH.
>> HARDWICK: VERY GOOD. POINTS.
>> THANKS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI.
>> HYMEN BREAKER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NATE.
>> UH, HOOF BLITZER.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI.
>> AIN'T NOBODY GOT TIME FOR
HATS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI.
>> GUY WHO RODE ME THROUGH THE
DESERT I DO HAVE A NAME IT'S
(BLEEP)ING BARRY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE.
>> LOOK AT THE DONG ON THAT ONE.
>> HARDWICK: DEFINITELY. POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
NIKKI.
>> SECRETLY A REALLY BIG DOG.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS TO NIKKI FOR
THAT.
(BELL DINGS)
MR. BARGATZE.
>> UH, DENNIS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, OF COURSE.
I DON'T SEE WHY NOT.
WHY CAN'T I HAVE A PERSON NAME?
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE.
>> UH, BORN IN THE U.S. OF HAY!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.